تخيل ان تخوض محادثه بالصوت والصوره مع
شخص متوفى هذا ما خطط له رجل كوري في
السادسه والسبعين من عمره حين علم انه في
المراحل الاخيره من مرض السرطان فاستعان
بشركه سجلته مقاطع مصوره على مدى ساعات
لانجاز نسخه رقميه عنه يمكنها خوض حوار
متكامل وبعد اشهر من وفاته جلس زوجته امام
شاشه تظهر صوره زوجها ليقول لها عزيزتي
هذا انا هذا كله نتاج الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذي استخدمته شركه ديب براين اي اي
لتطوير برنامج التي قالت انها لا تنشئ
محتوى جديد فهذه التكنولوجيا لا تولد
عبارات لم يكن المتوفى لينطق بها خلال
حياته وهو ذات المبدا الذي اعتمدته شركه
ستوري فايد التي قال رئيسها ان هذا المجال
حساس اخلاقيا ونحن نتخذ احتياطات كبيره
لكن هذه التكنولوجيا اخذ بالانتشار ففي
الصين مثلا تقدم بعض شركات تنظيم الجنازات
امكانيه التفاعل افتراضيا مع الاشخاص
المتوفين اثناء جنازاتهم وانتم شاركونا هل
يمكن ان تخوضوا يوما هذه التجربه